hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
summer 2013 edition in addition our
articles on wild woods des arts events
for everyone your local councillors
events and activities in the district
are you prepared for an emergency help
and advice on council tax and much more
but to start we have details of a new
smartphone app happy to help lots of
District Council has teamed up with
waste contractors Sita UK and mobile
application designers love clean streets
to make it even easier for residents to
report cleanliness issues with the
launch of a new smartphone app the
mobile application can be downloaded for
free at most smartphone device stores
whether it's litter fly-tipping dogs
miss cigarette butts or graffiti the
state of the art love clean streets app
lets you take a photo which will
automatically find where you are and
send the location and image straight to
the council's street scene team for
residents the app makes it easier to
report environmental issues and for the
council it means we're able to respond
quicker to clear up this don't worry if
you don't have a smartphone though you
can still report cleanliness issues in
other ways such as phoning the council's
customer services team on 0170 2318 one
double one or by emailing customer
services at Rochford goofy UK to
download the app go to your smartphone
device store and search the Rochford
cita and you should be able to find the
app did you know that the council has a
special facility in place that can help
organizations such as community and
voluntary groups sports and other clubs
schools social enterprises and small
businesses to search across a huge range
of funding sources free the council has
joined forces with grant net to provide
a certain
database of funding opportunities
ranging from European funds through to
Lottery awards and charitable trusts
grant net is completely free to use and
is available by clicking w WR OTE govt
UK forward slash france search it's a
really simple system to use you just
register your details and obtain a
password in order to search the system
for funds appropriate to your project
the consul's community planning officer
andrew lowing said this is an excellent
service and provides access to a wide
and varied range of funding bodies it
can be time-consuming finding the right
source of funding for your project and
the benefit of this service is that it
provides information on a full range of
UK and european union support provision
in a single searchable data place
suitable for all types of organizations
for more information or if you have any
questions about grant net you can
contact Andrew loving on 0 1 702 3180 61
and for more in-depth funding advice you
can contact the rayleigh Rochford and
district association for voluntary
services better known as ravs by
telephone on 0 1 2 68 double 727 96 drop
in to see revs as well as the council's
grant nets game you can also get help
and advice from the rayleigh Rochford
and district association for voluntary
services rats if you want to volunteer
but you're not sure how to go about
getting started or if you're a
charitable organization looking for
funding help or advice then make a date
to visit the ravs funding and
volunteering drop-in clinic on the last
tuesday morning of every month between
nine-thirty and 1230 revs will be at
number one west street rochford to help
you with advice and support there's no
need to book for this
just pop in for a chat and find out more
alternatively you can also pop in and
see your abs at their office at 105 high
street rayleigh revs has a wide range of
support on offer across the Rockford
district revs is once again running the
laptop courses which aimed help the over
25s learn computing skills in a relaxed
atmosphere laptop can help you with a
beginners computer course home visits
and a link to Rochford computer club all
in a relaxed atmosphere among the skill
was the course teaches our how to visit
websites that you've seen on television
how to send emails with photos attached
how to transfer photos from cameras to
computers and learn about internet
shopping the laptop contact rats on 0 1
2 68 double 727 96 or email revs that
double our AVS at ravs org UK district's
10th big day out around 3,000 people
came to Hollywood to help us celebrate
the 10th birthday of wild woods day they
all came along to enjoy loads of
activities from old favorites such as
the climbing wall and fencing to new
events such as a pop-up markets and
fresh local produce the event was also a
curtain-raiser to a busy year for the
new chairman of the Council Councillor
Bart Mrs Barbara Wilkins the chairman
said to start my year as chairman by
helping to celebrate the 10th birthday
of wild woods day was spectacular it's
so nice to see families coming to hockey
woods to enjoy all the different free
activities and if you enjoyed Wildwood
today why not try watch the district
summer holiday program the letter team
is once again working in partnership
with virgin active and ruptured extended
services to deliver a range of sports
and arts activities during summer
holidays activities include fencing
scuba diving badminton arts activities
theatre workshops and much more
activities will take place across the
Rockies
for children of all ages up to 16 for
more information visit www k /o ledee
activities or to be added to our mailing
list contact us by email leisure at
Rochford gov qk or phone 0 1 0 to 31 8
121 cycling your way to the games this
summer a series of lead rides or take
place across rockford castle point and
south end as part of the olympic legacy
these cycling your way to the games
rides are aimed at cyclists of all
abilities the rides will be divided into
three different styles off-road town and
rode the rides will vary in duration
with the shortest last in approximately
30 minutes to accompany the rides there
will also be talks delivered by experts
within recycling industry speakers will
cover a broad range of subjects from
nutrition to bike maintenance for more
information please call Richard Twomey
at the comfy saddle on 0 1 702 340 864
rocked William Castle Point sports
awards 2013 sponsored by virgin active
the 6th annual award take place in 2013
the nomination process opens shortly so
if you know a talented athlete of any
age a volunteer who deserves recognition
a sports club that has excelled or
someone that always participates in the
spirit of fair play then please take the
time to submit a nomination the awards
evening will take place later this year
with London 2012 bronze medal winning
hockey player Chloe Rogers on hand to
present their walls and a prize of 100
pounds for all winners more information
will be available shortly at wwu govt UK
forward slash sports awards or email
sport at Rochford gulf dot UK and we
will send you a nomination form as soon
as they are available arts events for
everyone whether it's watching or taking
part in something new there's arts
events go
or taking place in the district the
radio arts festival is on from Saturday
the 14th through to the end of sunday
the fifteenth of September so make a
date for this annual rayleigh arts
festival this year has a big focus on
heritage activities and events will take
place in and around the grade two listed
rayleigh windmill as part of the
national heritage open days initiative
look out for the full festival programme
by visiting w WH Fujio vuk forward slash
Arts Festival and that's in July
professional theater events for children
at the mill arts & Events Center have
proved popular with local families with
performances selling out in advance and
the next event will take place on sunday
the 15th of sep tember and it's based on
the popular children's picture book
don't let the pigeon drive the bus fresh
from a tour of the USA and canada this
lively show for children aged 3 and up
is full of fun feathers laughter and
excitement and it features original
music and lots of audience participation
you can join our mailing list for
families to receive news of when tickets
go on sale and with other
family-friendly activities and events in
the district by emailing arts at Watford
gavotte UK and then there's the Rochford
art trail this year 2013 this popular
arts trail returns with new dates and
more opportunities to explore the town
of Rochford and the work of more than a
hundred local artists the trail has been
extended from seven to ten days and will
run from Thursday the nineteenth to
saturday the twenty-eighth of sep tember
a pop-up arts and crafts marketplace
will be held on saturday the
twenty-eighth of September in the
Rockford WI Hall the trail map will be
available in the summer from the council
reception office at Raley and Rochford
you can download www Oxford govt UK
forward slash art trail and do make time
to visit the award-winning Railly
windmill once again the rayleigh
windmill has an exciting season of
exhibitions rolling until sep tember the
29th make time to visit local artist
Julia Tanner's exhibition which runs
until the 7th of July where then pleased
to welcome the stunning shine exhibition
between 10th of july and 14th of august
shine is a photographic exhibition which
is dedicated to the creativity of death
young people the final exhibition at the
wind bill will be sales in the wind from
the 17th of august to the 29th of sep
tember and it celebrates 200 years of
the windmill and takes you on a journey
through time using film and photographs
as well as exhibitions the museum at the
windmill holds a fascinating collection
of artifacts from rayleigh and the
surrounding area the collection has also
recently been awarded accredited museum
status from Arts Council England the
scheme sets agreed standards for museums
across the country to qualify museums
must meet standards on how they care for
their collections in their report the
panel praised the windmill for having no
areas for improvement one of just a few
museums to have reached this standard
the rayleigh windmill is open on
wednesdays between 10am and 1 p.m.
saturdays between 1pm and 4 p.m. and on
Sundays between 1pm and 4pm entries free
of charge but donations are always
welcome please note the rayleigh
windmill is sometimes closed for private
events so check the website at www UK /
windmill before visiting help with your
council tax if you are worried about
your financial health visit www k or
found them on oh 305
hundred 5000 between 8am and 8pm the
Money Advice service offer free unbiased
and independent financial advice they
can help you with managing your money
better how to review or reduce borrowing
money saving tips universal credit and
other benefits work and money bank
accounts and credit and debit cards
offering a helping hand if you are
getting council tax support and are
struggling to pay your council tax we
have a dedicated officer Laura pool who
can offer help and advice you can call
her on Oh 170 231 8089 visit her at the
council offices South Street Rochford
between 830am and 5 p.m. monday to
friday and request a home visit if you
find it difficult to get out laura is
working closely with the Citizens Advice
Bureau and may refer you to them for
advice on budgeting and managing debts
how to contact the Citizens Advice
Bureau this service helps people resolve
their legal financial and other problems
by providing a free confidential
independent and impartial advice and
information if you live in the district
or would like to speak to a member of
the bureau the current opening hours for
initial assessments are Rochford office
back lane rochford ss4 1a why open
tuesday and thursday 10 am-2 2 p.m. or
raley office civic sweet hockley road
rayleigh SS 680 be and they are open
monday thursday and friday ten a.m. to
2pm initial assessments are also
available by phoning 0844 for double 70
80 8 visit www k for initial information
on a variety of aspects of daily living
get your council tax bill through your
inbox not your letterbox help protect
the environment and save money visit w
wh the govt UK / paperless billing fill
in your name and address
click Submit and we will do the rest for
you essential living fund if you and all
your family are under exceptional
pressure with your finances you can
apply for a grant called the essential
living fund or elf the scheme
administered by southend-on-sea Borough
Council is designed to help those who
are in urgent need of assistance to
ensure they have basic living items such
as clothing food and fuel in order to
establish whether you are eligible you
will need to complete the online
application form this form will ask
questions about your income earnings and
savings you will also be required to
provide proof of your financial
situation if you are given a grant it
will not be paid via cash or direct into
a bank account indeed it will be paid by
the use of food vouchers or supermarket
vouchers use of all pay cards the
provision of recycled furniture from a
reputable charity provision of white
goods from a reputable local dealer
points of contact for general living
expenses meaning groceries nappies
toiletries hygiene products and fuel you
can apply by phoning the elf team on oh
379 double 0 1 2 4 and this number is
charged at local rates from any number
including mobiles the opening hours to
contact them are 8 45 a.m. to 5 15 p.m.
and for furniture white goods clothing
and footwear household equipment you can
use the online application form
available at www.sedar.com UK your local
councillors there are 39 councillors
19 19 Ward's or areas of the district
following the local elections in May the
political composition of the district
council is as follows 31 conservative
councillors for lib dem councillors to
green councillors and to Rochford
district residents councillors we will
shortly give you the names of the
counselor who represents you on lots of
a district council elections for Essex
County Council also took place on the
same day there are five Essex County
Council electoral areas within the
Oxford district these areas are known as
divisions and one councillor represents
each area the five essex county council
representatives for the Rochford
district are as follows rayleigh north
counselor Malcolm Maddox conservative
rayleigh self councillor Keith Gibbs you
Kip Rockford North counselor Terry cut
more conservative Rochford South
councillor Colleen segars conservative
Rochford west councillor michael hoy
Green Party and contact details for your
essex county councillors are available
at WWDC govt UK or by phoning Oh 1 2 4 5
430 481 ashington includin district mrs.
cape on a conservative teacup more
conservative council leader bowling and
sutton m steptoe conservative down hall
and laura see black liberal democrat and
liberal democrat ra autumn foulness and
great wakering te goodwin conservative
cg seekers conservative and councils
chairman conservative mrs. bj wilkins
and grange CJ Lumley lib dems and mrs.
dale Lumley lib dem councils vice
chairman
in Hawk rom north as mrs. L butcher and
mrs. J McPherson both conservatives in
Hawk well South you've brought mr. cape
on and mrs. Heather Glynn both
conservatives Hawk well west you've got
mr. John Mason who's the Rockford
district Resident Representative and
mrs. C Mason also Rochford district
representative hotly central you've got
three conservative candidates mr. Keith
Hudson he is also the deputy leader of
the council mrs. Weston mr. Hazelwood
hotly north you've got mr. Carter who is
a conservative and hot tea west mr.
Maddox also conservative in hullbridge
you have Michael hoy he's the Green
Party can't man and mrs. Hale she is the
conservative and also mrs. hoy she's
also the green party representative in
rayleigh Lodge ward you've got mr. d
Merrick and mr. I ward both
conservatives and in rayleigh central
you've got to conservative ladies mrs. P
aves and mrs. C row and the last five
districts are all conservatives Rockford
mrs. G Lucas Gill k j gordon and JP
Coty's Swain park mrs. J mock furred T
mountain Trinity DJ sparing je grey
wheatley JD Griffin and mrs. M Webster
and white house are our dre and SP
sniffed support shop at my local
businesses would you like to develop and
expand your business and increase your
customer numbers customers do you want
to get discounts at local shops would
you prefer to shop locally saving you a
long drive and getting stuck in traffic
all all-star also supporting local
businesses what is shop at my local the
shop at my loan
partnership delivers a range of projects
that encourage residents and businesses
to buy locally and regularly use local
supply chains the campaign aims to
ensure the district's shopping areas are
thriving community centers which offer a
unique and enjoyable shopping and social
experience the aim of the campaign
deliver initiatives and events that
attract people to the district's main
shopping areas be a forum to engage
local people in discussion help to
develop a shared strategic approach to
main shopping area development find
funding and resources to enhance
shopping areas help to deliver cleaner
greener and more attractive shopping
areas how will a member benefit you
firstly a membership is free once you've
joined you have access to the website
showing all the vouchers and offers that
are available at shops in the district
shops you may already be using you'll
also have access to competitions and
local information to date there are 1
837 shoppers signed up to the scheme and
432 traders what is Rochford doing roxas
economic development team needs your
help to develop shop at my local the
team consists of Judy Owen Humes
economic development manager and Sarah
Moss Business Support Officer they are
available to answer your queries on Oh
17025 463 double 6 and business at
Rochford gulf UK during the coming year
will be looking for opportunities to
enhance and promote various centers
within the district namely Rochford
rayleigh and hotly the district has a
unique character which must be preserved
whilst also ensuring that businesses
have the opportunities that they need to
survive and grow the council is
preparing action plans for the
development enhancement of those three
main centers more information can be
found on the website WWE are a govt UK
and a little later in
is addition one of the issues of growing
concern is the number of empty shops
across the district the tar incentive
have proved to be quite resilient during
the challenging financial times we have
been experiencing and there are fairly
few empty shops in the area the vacancy
statistics for primary shopping town
centers are three percent in rayleigh
seven percent in hotly and eight percent
in rockford nevertheless empty shops can
make the shopping areas look untidy and
won't contribute to making the areas
thriving community hubs the question is
though what can be done to help well
ideas from elsewhere include opening the
shops as pop-up shops and accompanying
this article are a couple of photographs
as to what they've done in Chelmsford
one is a community shop and the other is
an ideas hub where people presumably go
in off the street and ask about the unit
which is to let and there are various
ideas being put forward as to what
actually could happen within there now
these are used for a short period of
time and things like art displays art
exhibitions windows could be used to
display photographs of the area or any
art and marketing material created by
pupils at local schools now we want to
know whether you think that this is a
good idea you could email your thoughts
and suggestions to business at Rochford
dot dot dot UK what will rayleigh town
centre look like in the future more
shops more restaurants a different focus
to the high street how do you think the
centre of rayleigh should develop in the
future rajma district council is
currently holding an informal
consultation on the rayleigh area action
plan ray AAP until the eighth of august
2013 now this date is accurate at the
time of going to press but may be
subject to change in the event of
or seen circumstances so please check w
WR OTE gov UK or contact the planning
policy on 0 1 702 318 191 for the latest
information the ray AAP will form part
of the collection of documents that show
how the district will develop in the
future it sets out the council's vision
for the future of rayleigh town center
the overall role of the ray AAP is to
shape the development in the town center
for the next 10 to 15 years this
informal consultation represents a
chance for you to have your views heard
on what the council's policies for the
development of the town center should be
we've listened to your concerns
expressed through past community
involvement and have been working with
the consultant to produce a draft final
version of the area action plan we'd
like to hear from you whether you think
we've taken into account your
suggestions in the past to form this
draft final document what are your
thoughts on this document have you got
any ideas on how to revitalize the south
of the high street what kind of shops
would you like to see in rayleigh what
changes in the town center will
encourage you to do the shopping locally
would you like to see the size of the
taxi rank reduced as suggested in the
plan the draft Railly area action plan
can be viewed at Raley library and
council offices or online at www k we've
also prepared a questionnaire for you to
reflect your views and the questionnaire
is available at the council offices
south street rockford and rayleigh
library and online or if you wish by
post should you have any questions
regarding the Ray area action plan
please contact the planning policy on 0
17 and 23 18 19 1 are you interested in
how planning applications will be
determined in
future the development management
document will set out a wide range of
detailed policies which planning
applications will be assessed against
such as housing extensions limits design
rural diversification and species and
habitat protection are you interested in
the future of Rochford town center the
rockford area action plan will set out
planning policies specific to Rochford
town center including setting thresholds
for the types of uses within the town
center and improvements to pedestrian
routes within and around the town both
of these documents form part of the
collection of documents that will
determine how the district develops in
the future the final versions of the
development management document and the
rockford area action plan called the
submission documents or shortly go out
to formal consultation look out for your
opportunity to have your say online at
WWF a govt UK see the infocus section if
you would like to be notified of future
opportunities to comment on planning
policy documents sign up to the planning
policy teams mailing list in one of the
following ways online at Rochford dot j
dì hyphen consult net /l DF or send your
preferred contact details via email to
planning docked policy at Rochford WK or
phone 0170 23 18 19 1 out and about
we'll start with sports and leisure the
Rockford hundred Rugby Football Club is
a family-focused rugby club providing
facilities for rugby for all ages from
the under sixes through to adult and
veterans rugby teams matches occur
September to April inclusive on
Saturdays and Sundays training is all
the year round weekdays and saturdays
depending on the team's your contact
number for though is 0 17025 double 4021
the hawk well athletic FC summer soccer
school they meet on Friday evenings from
6 30 to 7 30 or eight and that's until
August the 30th each year fun football
training for girls and boys in reception
class or years one and two if you
haven't played football before and would
like to try it then go along to Hopley
community center and join in you can
just turn up on the day and you have to
please bring a non fizzy drink
appropriate Footwear and shin pads and
if the weather is hot Sun cream and at
the cost is 3 pounds per child per
session the contact them
www.aqualoja.net april until sep tember
16 sides all together for male and
female players of all ages and abilities
the contact for them chairman at really
Cricket Club all one long word dot org
dot u K or visit www Cricket Club org
dot u K fits why mark badminton club
meet every Monday evening from 7 30 29
30 and new members who play to a
reasonable level of badminton are being
sought to join the club's social club
they play on mondays at fits why mark
school you could contact the club
chairman by email worships at talktalk
dotnet clubs and groups Roche art group
meets Wednesday evenings between
seven-thirty p.m. and 9 30 at theresa's
church hall ashington rove rockford SS
for one hour f located to the rear of
the church there is good lighting and
facilities all abilities catered for at
this friendly club who use a variety of
media membership inquiries are always
welcome reasonable fees apply make a
note in your diary for the group's
annual exhibition taking place on
Saturday the 26 of october2013 at Santa
reasors between 10am and 4pm there is
free admission and parking for details
contact christine on 0 1 702 586 336 or
john on 079 double 3263 930 and rayleigh
horticultural society autumn show on
sunday the eighth of sep tember between
2 and 4 30 p.m. there is a show of
flowers vegetables floral art children's
classes and home crafts at the mill arts
& Events Center villiger malayan
rayleigh admittin is one pound with
accompany children admitted free there
will be items from the Society's trading
store available to buy together with
other stands you can find out more at
WWE horticultural society co uk please
note that although events are checked
before going to press they are subject
to change we recommend you visit our
website at www k or contact the
organizers to check before going to an
event council executive and committee
meeting dates all meetings will take
place in the council chamber civic sweet
to hotly road rayleigh SS 680 be
starting at seven thirty p.m. unless
otherwise stated the review committee
tuesday the 9th of july the executive
Wednesday the seventeenth of July
Development Committee thursday the
twenty fifth of july council Tuesday the
thirtieth of july development committee
thursday the twenty second of august
review committee tuesday the third of
sep tember the executive wednesday the
eleventh of sep tember development
committee Thursday the nineteenth of
September and for more information
contact member services on 0170 23
18 140 meet the new chairman counselor
mrs. barbara Wilkins is the new chairman
of Rochford district health after being
elected at the annual council meeting on
twenty first of may the new vice
chairman of accounts list counselor mrs.
june Lumley when will assist counselor
mrs. Wilkins during her term counselor
mrs. Wilkins is a district councillor
for fairness and great white cream ward
and has lived in the Rochford district
for 45 years she has been a district
councillor for 11 years and a parish
councillor for great white clean since
1986 she is a mother to one son and four
daughters and a proud grandmother to six
grandchildren counselor mrs. Wilkins has
worked with in a children's preschool
environment all her adult life and
continues to do so and thoroughly enjoys
going into work every day following her
election the new chairman of Rochford
District Council Councillor she's
welcome said I'm very proud to be
selected for this role by my fellow
councillors but I'm really looking
forward to a busy year ahead of me at
meeting so many people in the district I
would very much like to visit as many
schools and various organizations within
the district as possible and look
forward to receiving your invitations
the Chairman also announced that during
her year in office she would be raising
money for the Ryan Holly leukemia trust
fund South Essex Youth Symphony
Orchestra and the local multiple
sclerosis society if you would like the
chairman to attend an event you are
organizing or visit a group or
organization you are part of contact the
Chairman's office by pulling the Civic
officer Julia Mitchell on 0 1 702 3181
double for or email jr dr. Mitchell at
Rochford doctor shook a past chairman
honors our citizen of the year each year
the chairman of Rochford district
council presents the Citizen of the Year
awards they are made to recognize and
acknowledge residents in our district
for their valuable hard work and
outstanding achievement this year
nominations were invited in three
different categories young citizen
charitable support and community spirit
nominations poured in for people of all
ages and in all categories and the
judges were hugely impressed with the
sheer amount of hard work and dedication
of those who contribute to our community
from helping out at a local level
supporting neighbors friends and those
in need through to our young citizens
who work hard at school and are an
inspiration to their peers all the
individual achievements add up to a
community spirit that we should all be
proud of after a great deal of
deliberation the judging panel were keen
to give the Citizen of the Year award to
11 year old Leon thorne Leon has been
part of the 6th rochford scout group
since he was a beaver at age 6 he
contributes wholeheartedly being the
first to volunteer for new challenges
and activities his enthusiasm knows no
bounds and his happy demeanor spreads to
those around him what makes Leon's
examples their inspirational and
extraordinary is that he has Duchenne
muscular dystrophy there's a lovely
photograph accompanying this article
showing a very proudly on with his award
various people in the background
including the previous chairman
counselor mrs. Jerome Rockford all the
award winners and nominees were
celebrated at a gallery event hosted by
mrs. Montford to say congratulations and
to thank them for their hard work we
frequently get asked the question what
happens to my recycling once it's been
collected so we've put together answers
to the most popular questions but tell
you a little bit more about what happens
to your waist once we've got it once
collected all the recyclables are sent
for sorting at a materials recycling
facility mrf the MRF is operated by upm
chaton paper and is based in north east
wales on the same site as the facility
is you PM's paper
and this is where all Rochford's paper
is recycled to make new one hundred
percent recycled newsprint vehicles from
the chaton site distribute map
manufactured goods such as newsprint
throughout the UK including southeast
England the same vehicles that deliver
the manufactured goods can then be used
to collect and transport Rochford's
recyclables back to shorten the
transport system helps to reduce the
numbers of large goods vehicles on the
roads at the chaton facility all the
recyclables are sorted by a combination
of automated and manual processes so
that all the paper plastic glass
cardboard and metal tins and cans can be
bulked up separately and sent to re
processes within the UK for recycling
this means plastic bottles from Rochford
could end up being recycled into
clothing all returned back into milk
bottles for example answers to your
questions about recycling scheme why
can't I put soil or compost into my
compostables bin soil and compost cannot
be placed in the compostables green bin
because it does not compost down as both
products are in their final state and
cannot be treated further please ensure
you shake excess soil or root balls and
weeds before placing them in the
compostables theme if you do have any
excess soil or compost please reuse it
where possible or take it to the
recycling centres at Castle Rock Valley
or stop Road south end please note you
may need to produce your driving licence
or other identification why do I have to
rinse my recyclables before placing them
into the recyclables thin unclean
recyclable items should be rinsed before
being placed in the recyclables been as
the contents could cause problems at the
materials recycling facility food or
other residue could also soil other
items such as paper which could make
that item unsuitable for recycling what
is contamination the term contamination
is used to describe incorrect items in
the bins if you place items in the role
bins your bin may not be taken and it
may be stickered the sticker Willox
Blaine why your bins were not emptied on
this occasion if your bins are stupid
you should remove the incorrect items
from the bin and presented again on your
next relevant collection day what bin
should my food waste to go into all food
waste should be placed into your
compostables green bin with your garden
waste this includes cooked and uncooked
food meat fish and bones as well as tea
bags coffee grounds eggshells vegetables
and fruit peelings please do not place
any food or garden waste into the
recyclables gray or non cyclicals purple
bins now I'm sure we've all heard about
a message in a bottle but did you know
that if you do it as a possibility you
could win 50 pounds how I'll tell you
you need to get a ticket that's the
first thing so if you've got a kind
neighbor who gets rocks with district
matters as a paper give them a shout and
ask them if you can have their ticket if
not I'd give Rochford District Council a
ring and say look please will you send
me a ticket so that I could possibly win
50 pounds and this is what you have to
do the ticket it looks a bit like a big
goal to stamp it says message in a
bottle win 50 pounds by recycling your
glass bottles there's a space for your
name and your contact phone number and
what will happen is the idea is you take
this ticket with your information on you
pop it inside a clean glass bottle and
then you put that glass bottle with
hopefully the winning ticket in out week
commencing the eighth of July it's that
easy good luck with that now do you love
Rochford did you know that every day
approximately a hundred bags of litter
are collected from the Rockford area by
our contractors Sita UK did you also
know
that over the course of a year we
collect enough litter to fill the
freight house in Rockford and did you
know it costs nearly a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds a year to clean rochford
and this should not be the case there
are 16 litter bins throughout the
Rockford parish so what is litter still
thrown on the streets and just to
emphasize the point when I say Rochford
I don't mean the whole of Rochford
district I'm just talking about wrought
hood parish here the council are
starting a campaign to clean up the
streets in and around Rochford town
center and to make residents aware that
littering is against the law people who
drop litter can be fined or face
prosecution import authorized officers
have the power to issue a fixed penalty
charge of between 50 to 80 pounds for a
litter offense as an alternative to
prosecution litter can be anything from
a crisp packet or a cigarette butt to a
bag of rubbish the most common things
we've seen as litter include fast food
packaging sweet wrappers drinks cans
bottles and of course cigarette butts
litter doesn't clear itself away it can
take years to degrade causing harm to
wildlife and habitats as well as all of
this food that's dropped can attract
vermin we're urging residents to love
rochford by not dropping their litter by
either disposing of it in the nearest
litter bin or by taking it home the
street scene team will be out and about
in rochford over the summer carrying out
litter patrols identifying problem areas
and holding road shows if you live in
the Rockford parish and would like to
show your love for rockford by
volunteering to litter pick your area
we'd love to hear from you
please phone the street scene on 0 1 702
318 double 11 to register your interest
and the team will be continuing this
campaign in rayleigh hockley great
wakering and hullbridge later in the
year the gradual ations to Vanessa
Aldridge a member of hawk well girls
Brigade who's been recognized by the
council for her fantastic recycling
efforts Vanessa recently won a fancy
dress competition run by her local girls
Brigade when she designed and made a
fantastic outfit made out of recycled
materials the council's recycling team
was so impressed when they heard about
Vanessa's efforts that they wanted her
dedication recognized they organised for
Vanessa to be presented with a
certificate in April by the then vice
chairman councillor Barbara Wilkins to
congratulate her as being named our
first recycling champion we're sure it
isn't just Vanessa who's a clean
recycler in the district do you know of
someone who goes the extra mile to
recycle more someone who's clean on home
composting perhaps you know someone who
loves litter picking or sorts elderly
neighbors recycling for them we want to
celebrate the best of recycling in the
district after all you are among the
best in the country recycling over
two-thirds of your waist so if you know
someone who goes above and beyond when
it comes to recycling then do let us
know send your nominations to recycling
at Rochford gavotte UK or phone 0170
2318 one double one prepare for an
emergency emergencies can happen at any
time that's why it's important to be
prepared there are lots of things you
can do in advance so if an emergency
does happen you will be ready to cope
you can prepare the damage to your home
temporary evacuation or isolation by
putting together an emergency grab bag
with everything you need in it your grab
bag holds important personal information
and items which
may help in an emergency it should be
small enough for anyone to carry and
kept in a safe place that everyone in
your household from find before an
emergency think about situations such as
a fire flooding power cuts or extreme
weather talk about them discuss and
agree what you would do its best to
write down your plan but even having
discussed it can make a huge difference
to how you will cope whether it's the
minor incident or something worse in the
emergency if there's a major incident
stay home and tune in to your local
radio bbcs 610 3.5 and 95.3 FM heart FM
10 2.6 FM in the north and middle of s6
and 96.3 FM in south essex going spain
and tune in after an emergency your
health and recovery after an emergency
can be just as challenging visit w WR
see support essex all for information
about the prices support team ethics
there's lots more advice and information
on our website WWF ageru k /m urgencies
there are two labels you could use one
is your name and address and an
out-of-area contact name and telephone
number the second label reminds you of
what to put in your emergency grab bag
these could be prescription medicines
details for the family toiletries
identity documents first aid kit radio
battery or wind up torch battery or wind
up spare batteries notebook pen and
pencil spare glasses or contact lenses
mobile phone charger a contact list
including phone numbers insurance
details spare keys for house and car and
what else well of course there's always
chocolate more useful contacts wewt
essex hyphen fire WK WWE six police UK
www directgov UK ww NHS direct dot NHS
UK www rspca co uk ww environment hyphen
agency dots gloves you k a flood line 08
459 double it double one double eight or
the essex police non-emergency number
101 police commissioner visit a packed
audience that the hawthorne center in
rockford came to question the new police
and crime commissioner for essex
abbreviated to pcc mr. Nick Alston on
local policing issues mr. Alston is
visiting every local authority area in
Essex twice a year to listen to what
local people have to say about the
perception of policing and crime in
their area a panel including the chair
of the castle point and Rockford
District Community Safety Partnership
the CSP that's counselor mrs. Joe
Macpherson as well as chief inspector
ian cummings and inspector jeff arc will
be answered questions from the audience
on topics of concern including
antisocial behavior licensing and the
nighttime economy shoplifting and
vehicle crime and the pcc in the
audience heard how the local police and
partners including the council are doing
everything they can to stop unsightly
graffiti in the district as well as
implement measures to ensure the area
remains one of the safest cases to live
in the county especially at nighttime
following the meeting the PCC Nick
Alston said these public meetings are an
ideal way for me to listen firsthand to
the concerns residents have about their
community and how the police can help to
make them feel safer I
looking forward to coming back to the
district in a few months time to see for
myself what progress has been made with
the concerns people raised at the
meeting and how the local police have
taken steps to address those concerns a
major part of the discussions at the
public meeting with the PCC was about
how people who live in the Rockford
district can help keep it as one of the
safest places to live in the county the
council works very closely with Essex
Police and other partners to ensure the
district is a safe place for everyone to
enjoy this year the CSP priorities are
reducing domestic abuse reducing
antisocial behavior reducing reoffending
reducing serious acquisitive crime for
example dwelling burglary and theft from
Motor Vehicles and reducing a quiz ative
crime shoplifting and other burglary for
example sheds if you weren't able to
attend the last meeting with the PCC or
if you want to hear how things have
progressed since the last meeting then
make a note in your diary for the next
event which will be on the twenty-sixth
of September this year between 6pm and 8
p.m. at the grove wood primary school
grove round rayleigh pocket-sized help
for you the council's community safety
team has published a series of pocket
sized advice guides for residents with
tips on protecting their homes and
vehicles dealing with antisocial
behavior hate crime and domestic abuse
the aim of the leaflets is to raise
awareness of these issues outline what
steps residents can take and where help
and further advice is available the
concertina style leaflets are available
free from council offices and libraries
throughout the district alternatively
you can contact the community safety
team on 017 otome 318 104 and leaflets
will be sent out to you ASB pocket guide
enough is enough so report it a guide to
dealing with antisocial behavior in the
rocks
district this leaflet sets out in
unambiguous terms exactly what
constitutes antisocial behavior for
example at vandalism and useless
behavior and equally what doesn't such
as children playing in the street
antisocial behavior covers a wide range
of selfish and unacceptable activity
that can blight community life and
influence any form of intimidating or
destructive conduct that damages or
destroys another person's quality of
life the guide explains how the council
through its antisocial behavior officer
and its partners sets about tackling the
issue including spits to nip problems in
the bud through early intervention this
is backed up with a range of other
measures such as injunctions acceptable
behavior agreements and anti-social
behavior orders all at its disposal of
problems escalate it outlines what
residents can do if they are subjected
to or witness antisocial behavior
relation tact and her to call in the
event of emergency please remember if
you don't report it we don't know about
it domestic abuse panel castlepoint an
Oxford help and support pocket guide
domestic abuse where the physical or
emotional knows no boundaries and
happens in all kinds of relationships
the guide aims to address any gaps in
the knowledge de bout domestic abuse and
the help that is available to those in
an abusive relationship it also offers
practical guidance including developing
a safety plan and the help available
from national and local agencies the
safe and secure Pocket Guide most crimes
particularly burglary are
spur-of-the-moment actions often caused
by an opportunities such as an open
window by securing your home you save
yourself the distress and expense of
crime and make your community a safer
place the glyde also encourages
residents to be wary of bogus callers
who treat their way into a premises to
steal items while the occupier is
distracted hate crime pocket guide no
one should have to stand for it a guide
to dealing with hate crime in the
Rochford district nobody deserves to be
picked on or abused simply because they
are different but the reality is
that in today's diverse society people
are being labeled and victimized because
of their disability ethnic background
religion gender or sexual orientation
this leaflet explains exactly what hate
crime is and where anyone who feels they
are being discriminated against in this
way can get help vehicle crime Pocket
Guide offenses against vehicles
motorcycles and bikes account for a
disproportionate number of crime reports
to the police however most of these are
preventable the guide looks at tricks
used by thieves to steal vehicles
outlining how motorists can safeguard
themselves when buying a used vehicle
from a garage or privately or when
selling a used vehicle privately carers
enjoy half-term fun young carers from
across the district had a great week of
half-term fun with Essex County Fire and
Rescue Services in East TFRs the 12
teenagers were selected to take part in
a special fire break course run by ec
FRS in association with the Rockford
District Community Safety Partnership
the CSP and the carers charity scoffed
which stands for supporting carers and
families together firebreak is a life
skills and personal development program
which puts participants through the same
disciplines that recruit firefighters
learn including using breathing
apparatus taking control of high-powered
jet hoses ladder rescue and the
importance of teamwork the week-long
event at hawk crow fire station
culminated in a passing out ceremony
where the students demonstrated their
new skills in front of an audience which
included the venture man of Rochford
district councillor mrs. joan mock ferd
the idea for tailoring of course for
young carers arose from an earlier joint
initiative involving the fire service
the SC SP and staffed a series of
workshops were organised to raise young
people's awareness of how to stay
safe in all aspects of their daily lives
and this included vital fire safety
advice Lin ketley from EC RFS said the
workshops were very successful with the
young carers and led to four young
carers being recommended and awarded
cases on our young firefighters courses
and scuffed being awarded this fire
break course while the firebreak course
had it serious aspects it was devised
with the emphasis on fun something that
can be missing in the lives of young
carers given their circumstances scalped
works to provide help support and
information to carers of all ages
looking after a relative friend or
neighbor who thought through long-term
illness disability and other reasons may
need extra support to manage some
aspects of their daily lives and there
is a photograph accompanying this
article that shows I think a young
person kind of scrambling up a ladder
with a firefighter behind giving them a
friendly push if you'd like more
information on the SCAF you can visit
their website at WWDC fe org UK top
summer security tips to ensure you can
relax and enjoy the summer essex police
is crime prevention officer for the
rockford district Emma Clark has some
advice for keeping garden equipment safe
from theft top of her list of tips is
sheds and outbuildings security sheds
and outbuildings typically contain tools
and gardening equipment which are not
just valuable but could also prove
useful to a burglar looking to break
into your home secure the shed door with
pad bolts and closed shackle padlocks
that cannot be easily apprised off or
fit a padlock alarm hindi should be
fitted using culture bolts and large
backing washers doors can be further
secured with shed alarms and a shed bar
lock Emma said larger items such as
bikes ladders and lawn mowers should
ideally be chained to a shed shackle on
the wall or to an i-type anchor
fixed into a concrete floor inside the
shed it's advisable to make a note of
all gardening equipment recording the
make model and serial number and to mark
all items in a highly visible manner
such as scratching or inject engraving
or using a permanent Security marker
showing their postcode and house number
or name this will make them less
attractive to a thief if you keep your
gardening tools and equipment in your
garage don't advertise their presence to
passing strangers by leaving the door
open for long periods there's lots more
information about home security on our
website at www k Roger district matters
is designed and published by rockford
district council its editor is patrick
john the telephone number for the
council is 0 1 702 546 366 and the
magazine is printed by Morton
print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6 that
brings us to the end of sedition which
was recorded by volunteers from the
rayleigh Rockford and Castle Point
talking newspapers for the blind at
their studio in rochford rotary district
matters is designed and published by
rockford district council its editor is
patrick john the telephone number for
the council is 0 1 702 546 366 and the
magazine is printed by Morton
print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6 that
brings us to the end of sedition which
was recorded by volunteers from the
rayleigh Rochford and castle point
talking newspapers for the blind at
their studio in rockford